et puis cet amour qui vous est tombé
dessus en quelque sorte il y a presque
un an c'est votre petite fille Esmeralda
cet amour-là il ne se catégorise pas en
quelque sorte il est plus fort que tout
plus fort que vous j'imagine ouais je
sais même pas c'est le mot amour
c'est tellement tellement de de
sentiment qui se confondent qui
deviennent surpuissant qui qui éclate
tout sur leur passage à l'intérieur à
l'extérieur aussi et que c'est ouais
c'est un raz-de-marée d'amour votre
petite Esmeralda elle a presque un an
bon je prends un tout petit peu d'avance
vous avez été très inquiet à sa
naissance vous avez eu la peur de la
perdre parce que son cœur avait du mal à
battre correctement elle avait du mal à
se nourrir maintenant tout va bien et
c'est formidable et puis vous avez été
formé un peu au biberon la nuit parce
que vous étiez un fêtard aujourd'hui
c'est les biberons qui vous réveillent
comment vous vous occupez des Smeralda
avec la tournée
avec l'organisation quand vous êtes en
studio quel papa êtes-vous moi je suis
un papa hyper présent en tout cas c'est
de l'être au maximum je prends ma fille
avec moi en tournée donc elle est en
train de visiter toute la France la
semaine prochaine la Belgique
et non comment je m'organise ben j'ai
une famille qui m'aide beaucoup aussi
mes parents sont vraiment là mais sœurs
aussi mon frère pareil
et je ouais j'essaie d'être là un
maximum j'essaie de de dès maintenant
parce que je crois que ça commence en
fait assez vite de donner tout ce que je
peux lui donner alors je sais pas si je
fais bien si les pédopsychiatres diront
que c'est bien mais moi je parle déjà à
ma fille un peu comme si c'était une
adulte quoi une adulte je me comprend
mais
d'intégrer en tout cas exactement et
je suis déjà en train de me poser des
questions sur ce que je veux lui laisser
et ce que je veux surtout pas lui
laisser aussi et c'est trop important
c'est avec ce titre à fleur de toi de
que vous êtes retrouvé à chanter au
casting
on vous a poussé un peu vous aviez posté
des vidéos sur YouTube ouais en fait
pour savoir pour dire la vérité mais on
m'a appelé dès la première saison de The
Voice Bruno berbas m'a appelé pour
passer les auditions et à l'époque
j'avais l'impression de pas du tout
correspondre à ce qui pouvait se faire
et
il y a eu Pigalle comme vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure et je
un jour voilà je reprends cette chanson
à fleur de toi et je me rends compte
qu'il y a il y a un monde quoi il y a un
truc qui se passe quand c'est cette
chanson là bien particulière en
particulier pardon et
du coup je la poste sur Youtube et
je reçois un coup de fil de The Voice
qui me dit bon là vas-y cette année il
faut que tu le fasses et c'est tout et
je vois que les gens ont une réaction
même mes autres vidéos je sais pas à
l'époque ça devait faire 10 000 vues bah
là ça faisait 100000 vues quoi et il y a
eu un truc ouais qui s'est passé avec
cette chanson et et cette vie qui
bascule parce que je me dis que bah ok
allez je vais aller la chanter quoi
est-ce qu'il y a eu aussi et est-ce que
ça c'est toujours là un peu comme ça en
filigrane votre image la question de
votre image c'est que vous avez vous
avez été en surveillance quasi
quotidienne pendant des années parce que
il y a eu cette obésité cette souffrance
aussi est-ce que c'est toujours le cas
une sorte d'alerte permanente
en trois images on voit trois slimanes
différents il y a celui qui était tout
mince ça The Voice celui qui était gros
à l'Olympia il y a ceux qui entre les
deux aujourd'hui
c'est
c'est un truc qui m'a marqué et c'est ça
aussi c'est que j'étais pas fini en fait
même si j'avais 26 ans j'étais pas fini
dans ma tête j'avais encore trop de
doutes sur moi trop de trucs à régler
pour que d'un seul coup les gens
puissent avoir un avis sur moi moi
j'avais pas qui j'étais donc les gens
qui avaient un avis sur moi c'était
compliqué et ce truc du poids ouais
c'est quelque chose qui me suit qui me
suit et qui me suivra jusqu'à là je
pense très très vieux c'est quelque
chose qui m'a Traumat disais
en France a été compliqué l'adolescence
moi j'avais un problème de gynécomastie
en plus donc pour ceux qui savent pas
c'est quand on a un développement des
glandes mammaires pour un homme qui est
trop
accentué donc on a l'impression à
l'adolescence alors avec mes longs cils
et le début de ça là je ressemble à une
fille et
et il y a ce rapport-là avec les autres
tu vois genre j'avais un souvenir en à
la piscine ou un jour il y a en plus un
presque un grand quoi il devait avoir 20
ans le gars à 22 ans qui me dit mais
c'est pas le truc c'est pas le vestiaire
des filles ici et c'est des choses qui
te marquent en fait et qui et qui sont
qui qui gèrent je crois un peu tout ton
rapport aux autres moi ça je sais que ça
a joué vachement pour le fait que je
devienne chanteur sur sur mes rapports
de de séduction sur sur l'amour sur le
couple ça ça joue beaucoup c'est
incroyable ce qu'on a vécu je n'aurais
pu le vivre avec personne d'autre je
crois c'est un amour tellement sincère
une amitié tellement tellement belle
franchement c'est je sais que ça restera
une des plus belles aventure de de ma
vie versus et nous d'ailleurs faut
savoir en ce projet là c'est pour ça que
c'est pas c'est un vrai projet c'est que
nous dès le début dès qu'on nous en a
parlé des gens on a refusé à la base on
voulait pas du tout le faire on a voulu
aller en studio d'abord faire des
chansons voir si ça fonctionnait et
ensuite tout de suite ça a été le point
important c'était que on voulait le
faire sur scène on voulait pas que ce
soit juste un disque et
on a fait une tournée qu'on est en train
de faire une tournée qui a plus de 110
dates 115 dates je crois et et c'est
juste c'est juste incroyable le public
les gens c'est fou elle est la seule à
avoir le droit de vous appeler slim chou
c'est une chose les mou et toi elle le
sait maintenant elle en joue
mais oui ouais en vrai elle est là faut
pas m'appeler comme ça
elle est évidemment importante dans
votre carrière c'est une amie une sœur
c'est aussi pour Esmeralda quelqu'un qui
vous conseille elle est maman et vous
avez été vous avez été parents
pratiquement simultanément de nouveau
j'ai toujours qu'on est tombé enceinte
en même temps
ouais ouais c'est quelqu'un qui me
conseille c'est dans cette relation là
ce qui a été beau c'est que franchement
on parle pas tant de musique que ça pour
être très franc là par contre mon studio
qu'on fait les chansons mais on est de
vrais amis c'est une grande sœur elle me
conseille sur plein de choses c'est
quelqu'un de beaucoup plus calme que moi
elle c'est un peu l'eau moi c'est le feu
et c'est vrai que ça ça
quand c'est bien fait ça va bien
ensemble